bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 week-end comme
tous les vendredis vous le savez nous
revenons sur les moments forts de
l'actualité Sport Loisirs et Culture au
cours de cette émission nous parlerons
danse traditionnelle un balbreton est
organisé ce samedi à Guyancourt nous y
reviendrons tout à l'heure avec
Marie-claude Riocreux présidente de
l'association caliburden mais le
démarrons tout d'abord avec de l'art
très particulier à l'hôtel de ville de
Maurepas jusqu'à la semaine prochaine
les ateliers du Mercantour vous font
découvrir les techniques d'encadrement
d'oeuvres artistiques un véritable
travail de précision et de patience un
reportage signé Aurélia Debussy et
Elodie
découpe en biseau prolongation d'images
bandes superposées il existe de
multiples techniques d'encadrement d'art
jusqu'au 14 février les ateliers du
Mercantour exposent 300 modèles salle du
conseil de la mairie à Maurepas des
pièces uniques réalisées par les 200
élèves de l'association l'encadrement
d'art consiste à exploiter l'image
chaque image a quelque chose de
particulier
on encadrera pas de la même façon un
animal qu'une vue sur une campagne ou
quelque chose et là c'est d'exploiter
cette différence ou cette particularité
de l'image choix des matériaux
conception du décor harmonie des
couleurs l'encadrement d'art est un
travail de création et de précision en
moyenne 3 à 5 heures sont nécessaires à
la création d'un cadre la mise en valeur
de certains documents peut parfois
demander davantage de patience un très
bel encadrement d'art c'est quelque
chose qui sort d'ordinaire
ou le regard reste attiré en premier par
la pièce maîtresse l'image un superbe
travail autour mais qui ne se voit pas
qui fait un tout avec le document parce
que si jamais
l'oeil est attiré par l'encadrement
plutôt climat alors là il y a une erreur
maintenant il y en a qui choisissent sur
des choses très modernes c'est
l'encadrement autour qui devient
l'oeuvre maîtresse peu importe ce qu'il
y a dedans c'est exceptionnel quand même
depuis 30 ans les ateliers du Mercantour
exposent deux fois par an leur plus
belles œuvres à l'issue de la visite le
public peut voter pour son coup de cœur
accueille une étrange de machines à son
capable de transformer les bruits du
quotidien je ne vous en dis pas plus
c'est je vous laisse découvrir ce
reportage d'Aurélia Debussy et
d'élodymone
sous ses airs sortis tout droit d'un
roman de Jules Verne la Machine à
explorer les sons vous invite à la
découverte de l'électro-acoustique
installé dans le hall du centre culturel
La Barbacane à Beynes cet étrange
machine propose diverses pistes
d'exploration musicale et sonore
l'électro-acoustique permet de
transformer des sons des bruits du
quotidien en un langage musical donc
l'idée même c'est que on est tous
créateurs de quelque part de musique en
donnant un sens à des bruits donc là
quand on va écouter les critiques liées
à l'allumage des langues ou quand on va
écouter les réverbérations les
résonances du lieu quelque part on
découvre que ce lieu qui est rempli de
plus ou moins de bruit de son devient
prend un sens devient une musique et on
peut l'apercevoir comme tel 5
dispositifs d'écoute autour de la
machine vous invite à l'expérience il
suffit de prendre un casque utiliser les
sons et bruit et les transformer en
musique
et
acoustique permet à des auditeurs qu'ils
soient qu'ils aient une culture musicale
avancée ou simplement un désir d'être
surpris de découvrir que le monde
musical nous entoure réellement qu'ils
sont aussi acteurs de ce monde musical
sans même avoir des compétences
cela fait givre ou instrumental conçu
pour la compagnie inouï actuellement en
résidant artistique cette installation
interactive est en accès libre jusqu'à
fin mai
c'est un héros incontournable de la
bande dessinée contemporaine Philippe
Luguy dessinateur des aventures de
percevant nous a reçu lors d'une journée
de dédicace à Voisins-le-Bretonneux un
portrait signé Aurélia Debussy et
Michael Jarry
adolescent Philippe Leguy voulait
d'abord se diriger vers le dessin animé
puis de rencontres en première
publication se dessinateur au todidacte
se tourne alors vers la bande dessinée
dans la continuité d'Hergé ou encore
Peio ses dessinateurs de série avec un
personnage central Philippe Luguy crée
notamment en 1981 percevant un héros
incontournable de la bande dessinée
contemporaine on est parti avec le
scénariste Jean leturgie sur le principe
d'un héros j'aime pas beaucoup le mot
mais qu'on appelle creux c'est à dire
c'est le héros dans lequel a priori le
lecteur peut prendre la place c'est
l'exemple de Tintin par exemple Tintin
quand on lit Tintin on devient Tintin
percevant n'est moins percevant que on
ne devient Tintin mais c'est un peu ce
principe de fonctionnement
l'inconvénient de ce genre de personnage
c'est que étant un peu transparent d'une
certaine façon il a besoin d'être
flanqué d'une galerie de personnages
autour qui le tiennent et qui donne
toutes les sens et tout le corps de la
série et percevant à cette particularité
c'est que on l'a voulu à l'époque on a
voulu faire un héros sexuel et qui a des
aventures amoureuses c'était une
dimension qu'il n'y avait pas dans la
bande dessinée à cause de la censure
sur fond de dessin humoristiques
percevant un chevalier d'un Moyen-Âge
fantastique voyage dans des royaumes
imaginaires et merveilleux
on a choisi le moyen-âge parce qu'on
aimait bien le moyen-âge tous les deux
et parce que c'est une période
extrêmement vaste permettant une grande
interprétation et qui permettant de
délirer et de toucher tous les sujets
c'est une période qui est fabuleuse
parce que c'est une période où il y
avait des grandes superstitions donc
voilà on peut on peut jouer avec et puis
les légendes c'est les légendes sont
très prégnantes etc etc donc les
costumes enfin tout Philippe Luguy
marque la bande dessinée depuis
maintenant une trentaine d'années
dernier album de la série les 8e royaume
publié aux éditions Dargo et sorties en
on reste en culture avec le festival
international de court-métrages à
Jouy-en-Josas pour cette cinquième
édition 38 films ont été sélectionnés
Franck Villette président et
organisateur du festival était l'invité
de l'émission kiosque cette semaine nous
l'écoutons le but d'un court-métrage
c'est vraiment d'aller à l'essentiel
pour moi en général ça dure entre une et
50 minutes on englobe aussi le moyen
métrage avec aller à l'essentiel
vraiment raconter une histoire en très
peu de temps
c'est pas un petit film de vacances
sérieuse tous les cas c'est pour moi
c'est vraiment quelque chose de sérieux
c'est un travail à part entière c'est
une oeuvre comme comme un long métrage
et certains certaines personnes c'est
vrai
pensent que c'est que c'est oui un film
de vacances comme comme vous le dites
de festivals de courts métrages en
France et c'est vrai que c'est pas c'est
pas encore c'est pas encore ça voilà on
a encore du travail pour démocratiser un
petit peu tout ça moi je vous propose
qu'on regarde justement la bande-annonce
de ce festival ça nous donnera une idée
des films qui vont être en compétition
tu fais quoi ce soir
vous avez donc jusqu'à dimanche pour en
profiter je le disais dans les titres de
cette édition un bal breton est organisé
ce samedi à Guyancourt ce sera dès 20h à
la Maison de Quartier Auguste Renoir
pour en parler avec nous l'une des
organisatrices Marie-Claude de riz au
creux présidente de l'association
caliburden bonjour Marie-Claude François
alors pour commencer peut-être pouvez
nous expliquer un peu ce le principe de
ces balles bretons nous présenter un peu
et bien nous organisons donc ce bal
breton comme nous faisons le faisons
plusieurs fois dans l'année et
ce mal nous faisons venir un orchestre
qui se qui s'appelle les calliornes
c'est un groupe de 6 musiciens et un
chanteur qui composent et qui
écrit leur chanson de
tradition bretonne
et donc ils vont animer donc cette
soirée parce qu'il y a un objectif
particulier assez bas est-ce que c'est
juste le plaisir de se retrouver
ensemble ou bon entre autres oui et là
se balle
est organisée aussi pour récolter des
dons pour le l'association d'aide
alimentaire bouchées donc nous ferons un
appel à tous les
participants
alors il y a l'entrée qui est de 5 euros
mais en plus nous aurons une boîte où
nous récolterons enfin une urne où nous
récolterons des dons pour l'association
d'accord alors en règle générale
beaucoup de véritables bretons bien
assez balles ou pas forcément c'est
beaucoup de bretons sur la ville
nouvelle donc nous avons effectivement
une participation de breton mais aussi
d'autres personnes qui aiment beaucoup
les danses et
danser tout simplement d'accord alors
comment ça se passe vous proposer des
costumes aussi pour reblonger bien dans
les potes
les gens viennent avec leur habit
comment ville d'accord leur habit de
ville non non nous ne faisons pas de
costumes folkloriques
ce qu'on appelle une auberge espagnole
ceux qui veulent participer viennent
avec un plat de leur composition et que
nous partageons tous ensemble alors ce
type de danse bretonne donc c'est assez
particulier est-ce que c'est que du
collectif donc c'est en rond ou en
couple c'est pas des danses
individuelles non ce sont des danses en
groupe bon vous avez différentes danses
type Andrew en terre drops la ridée
enfin beaucoup de danse typ iquement
bretonne et
que enfin libre Ton connaisse
pratiquement toutes et qui sont importés
de tout ça après deux ou trois
démonstrations enfin deux ou trois pas
tout le monde peut les danser d'accord
justement j'allais vous demander est-ce
que c'est compliqué parce que c'est
quand même assez rythmé il faut savoir
suivre le rythme mais en général dans
les balles on fait des des dents des
danses qui sont apportées de tous
les unes qui sont plus ou moins
difficiles mais en général ce sont des
danses à portée de tous quelqu'un qui
n'a aucune notion donc peut venir à
séparer il pourra s'en sortir
après une démonstration il pourra très
bien s'en sortir avec le groupe d'accord
c'est dur combien de temps
en général c'est long c'est une danse ça
fait quatre quatre cinq minutes
et alors est-ce qu'on peut dire que
c'est un type de danse
intergénérationnelle est-ce que les
enfants aussi sont conviés tout le monde
peut danser ce type de danse c'est ce
sont des danses intergénérationnelles et
les enfants les ados tout le monde les
personnes des des jeunes des moins
jeunes peuvent danser toutes ces danses
ça reste quand même une activité
d'adulte entre guillemets les jeunes ne
sont pas forcément
dans la région parisienne nous avons
beaucoup de mal à recruter des anneaux
mais nous nous espérons toujours pouvoir
le faire mais bon il arrive que
quelquefois nous ayons des ados dans ce
genre de manifestation qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait faire alors pour attirer alors
je pense qu'il faudrait pouvoir
toucher les jeunes dès leur plus jeune
âge pour pouvoir les amener à participer
à ce genre de choses c'est à dire en âge
scolaire
des enfants des et qui continueraient
par la suite d'accord alors au niveau de
la musique vous l'avez dit un véritable
orchestre sur la sur place quel type de
musique qui vont jouer quel type
d'instruments alors ce sont des
commandes des instruments de
type traditionnel breton
des petits exemples d'instruments alors
bon je pense qu'il y a la vieille le je
pense qu'il y a le comment
ça vous revient pas oui
association donc elle existe depuis 7
ans elle s'appelle caliburden
pourquoi ce nom c'est
une
danse
assez rythmée et chevlée
c'est une danse du Morvan de tradition
plutôt gauloise qui se danse en général
comment avec des flambeaux allumés et
c'est pour comment
purifier la terre et le ciel enfin pour
bon c'est une danse et qui a été dansé
la première fois justement en spectacle
par pour le premier spectacle de
caliberden d'où d'accord donc proposer
des ateliers toute l'année c'est sa
musique chant danse oui alors nous avons
atelier musique qui est ouvert à des
gens qui qui connaissent nous faisons
pas d'apprentissage déjà des gens qui
connaissent la musique et ce comment cet
atelier a lieu le lundi nous avons un
atelier chant qui fait particulièrement
des danses des champs à danser qui a
lieu le mercredi et un atelier danse
alors il y a un atelier danse il y a une
partie où il y a de l'initiation pour
les débutants
une partie
de l'atelier qui est consacré à
comment
au partage c'est à dire les gens qui
sont beaucoup plus
perfectionnés qui entraîne les les
débutants et un atelier plus technique
qui prépare les spectacles auxquels on
participe très bien je vous remercie
alors vous l'aurez compris si vous
voulez vous initier ou vous
perfectionner à la danse bretonne
rendez-vous demain à Guyancourt c'est 5
euros par personne et tous les bénéfices
seront donc reversés à l'association
d'aide alimentaire bouche et cœur
on passe maintenant à la commune de
plaisir plus de 2000 livres CD et DVD
étaient proposés lors d'un troc il y a
quelques jours un mode de consommation
qui semble revenir au goût du jour un
reportage de Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
lors de cette quatrième édition le
record est déjà battu plus de 2000
livres CD et DVD ont été échangés entre
les troqueurs ce week-end d'un plaisir
ici elle leur arrivée les organisateurs
mettent des points à chaque article
amenés par les participants en fonction
de leur valeur avec leur point les
troqueurs peuvent ensuite se servir j'ai
amené beaucoup de DVD et de CD j'ai eu
beaucoup de points donc j'en ai profité
pour me faire une vraie bibliothèque
jeunesse
qui va mettre très utile la bibliothèque
est encombrée donc envie de renouveler
envie que ça profite à quelqu'un donc
voilà c'est aussi un lieu de rencontre
et puis
ça permet de se donner des idées
savoir qui a aimé quoi et de partager
des lectures aussi
voilà puis ça évite d'acheter et on peut
mettre le budget d'une autre manière
à l'origine de cet événement
l'association des résidents des Gâtines
et du plateau de plaisir en quatre ans
pour élargir leur public plusieurs
concepts ont été créés comme ce coin
enfant ou encore ces articles spécial
coup de cœur la nouveauté cette année
c'est l'espace gratuit le but ici c'est
au-delà du troc c'est c'est surtout
faire plaisir aux gens qui viennent et
c'est faire en sorte qu'ils repartent
avec des livres donc on a fait un petit
coin un petit peu à entre guillemets
gratuits ou là il y a pas besoin il y a
pas besoin d'échanges une partie des
stocks restants est ensuite reversée à
des associations plaisiroises
le vélodrome de 50 ans en Yvelines
attire tous les regards et la curiosité
le week-end dernier près de 12000
visiteurs ont pu le découvrir lors de
journées portes ouvertes Anthony Reich
chez Patrick Jacques delixmude était sur
place
sur le parvis les fils d'attente sont de
plus en plus longues pendant de jours le
vélo Drôme ne 50 ans en Yvelines a
ouvert ses portes au grand public et un
seul mot vient à la bouche des visiteurs
c'est vrai que c'est très très
impressionnant toute la voûte qu'il y a
au dessus avec tous les espèces de rail
je sais pas ce que c'est mais c'est une
construction qui est très
impressionnante oui
à peine entrer dans l'enceinte les
curieux aperçoivent la piste olympique
et la plupart s'attardent à contempler
cet outil unique au monde en tribune
c'est très aéré vraiment je pense qu'on
a un point de vue magnifique sur la
piste et l'air centrale n'importe où on
se trouve dans le dans l'installation
donc c'est très très bien belle
réalisation
des gradins au centre de la piste il ne
fallait descendre que quelques marches
pour se retrouver exceptionnellement sur
l'aire centrale zone habituelle de
l'échauffement des professionnels
l'occasion d'approcher l'équipement
spécifique nécessaire pour la piste on
en a un mais pour la route il y a des
freins il y a tout ça celui-là il est un
peu plus léger
il y a le minimum strict minimum il fait
quand même ça doit pas ça va pas te
donner ça
c'est très beau ça fait envie d'en faire
si cette opération permet de faire
découvrir le Centre national du cyclisme
elle pourrait faire naître quelques
vocations la piste est une discipline
assez méconnue parce qu'il y a très peu
de vélo de drôles encore moins de ce
calibre là parce que on peut considérer
que le site est vraiment unique donc
voilà c'est forcément quelque chose
qu'il faut démocratiser et puis qu'il
faut expliquer aux gens du territoire
qui sont pas tous des cyclistes voilà ce
week-end 12000 personnes ont pu
découvrir le Vélodrome
au Vélodrome toujours au lendemain de
son inauguration Robert Marchand 102 ans
a battu son propre record de l'or après
avoir parcouru près de 27 km Anthony
Rech et Elodie moi l'ont rencontré ce
jour-là
les 500 personnes présentes dans les
tribunes du Vélodrome de 50 ans en
Yvelines ont du mal à y croire la grande
aiguille de l'horloge n'a pas encore
effectué un tour complet que Robert
Marchand a déjà amélioré son propre
record de l'heure j'espère faire ça dans
quelques années mais
102 c'est pas mal pour faire ça toute
façon à son âge il est obligé de pas
d'avoir un régime alimentaire etc Un
hygiène de vie correcte ça c'est certain
c'est obligé pourtant une heure
auparavant le cyclisme balmarder
semblait moins confiant je parle dans le
néant je ne sais pas
si je vais le badge je ne sais pas je
peux pas vous dire
ça dépend surtout que j'ai pas j'ai pas
vraiment
monsieur pas entrer vraiment en
conséquence je me suis pas entrer mais
enfin j'ai pas d'excuse
après cette équipe et le champion
paralléchauffement et impressionne déjà
les plus grands la vitesse il est bien à
l'allure bon c'est vrai que il est pas
très heureux dynamique parce qu'il
arrive pas vraiment à bien se pencher
sur le sur le vélo mais là il tourne à
une à une allure on a l'impression qu'il
pourrait tourner pendant deux heures
comme ça un bon tout à l'heure il a
tourné un petit peu plus vite là il y a
du chauffement dès les premiers tours de
pistes Robert Marchand tournent les
jambes comme un cadet applaudit par les
supporters venus de toute la France à
chaque passage c'est la 56e fois que
Robert Marchand passe derrière moi en 30
minutes sur cette piste du vélodrome de
50 ans en Yvelines pour l'instant il
roulait une allure moyenne de 26,8 km
heure le record du monde et donc bien
parti
le centenaire né le 26 novembre 1911
possède selon ses médecins les capacités
cardiaques d'un homme de 50 ans pour ce
record l'Union Cycliste Internationale a
créé spécialement cette catégorie pour
lui
après une heure d'effort du haut de son
maître 51 Robert Marchand a réussi son
pari 26 km 927 parcourus record
pulvérisé pourtant il aurait pu mieux
faire
j'étais pas avoir en forme j'étais pas
en grande forme j'étais
seulement ta retenue on recommence et
quand on lui a demandé s'il pensait déjà
au prochain record il a répondu qu'il
voulait d'abord continuer à vivre
on termine cette édition avec votre
agenda du week-end tout d'abord du sport
avec la toute première compétition
officielle au Vélodrome la coupe d'hiver
de cyclisme surpiste se déroule ce
samedi 8 février de 14h à 18h30 c'est
gratuit pour les licenciers de la FFC et
5 euros pour les non licenciés ce samedi
toujours à 18h30 vous pourrez assister à
l'avant-première du film se battre un
film qui rend hommage au bénévoles du
Secours populaire français ce sera aussi
nécessaire d'Élancourt c'est la fin de
cette édition merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain rendez-vous lundi en direct dès
18h pour le 7 8 l'actu avec wilfriedish
Ricci d'ici là je vous souhaite un
excellent weekend sur tvfils